two welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience this is the
without ela with ethan uh experience
that is the episode because ela is uh
with peace and love too busy
so we're we're frankly still having an
identity crisis over here
if it's not good luck ethan thank you
yeah if you couldn't tell where i
i don't know i don't know how to label
this episode but i think it's just ethan
without
ela experience and i don't i don't know
that i like that experience
off the rails people are saying that i
always get canceled without ela
canceled maybe just be well canceled
sounds like a donald trump junior book
wait wait did he really write a book
called cancelled no he wrote one called
triggered oh triggered i think canceled
but it's not like ironic it's serious
it's like no i'm gonna get canceled
since ela's not here
this is how i feel without ela i don't
know if you guys are familiar with the
sound but in the morning
think about so many things just want to
get better
that's how i feel without ela
who's today's episode up stamps.com and
upstart
we love our sponsors don't we folks
thank you
thank you you know today we have what i
consider to be a really
special fun exciting episode you guys
have probably heard about all the craze
with the
ntfs non-fungible tokens nfts
i was looking right at it and i still
said it wrong nfts non-fungible tokens
you guys heard about it i'm sorry
joe i think joe the gaff machine of all
people
for example like there's been a lot of
crazy sales the neon
cat meme sold for six hundred thousand
dollars
this month or last month about a month
ago grimes sold pieces of art for four
hundred thousand brock come on
oh this dude i don't get this here i'm
gonna show you this real fast
this sold for 6.6 million dollars
okay which by the way it's cool and all
but somebody bought this for 6.6 million
dollars now i don't we're trying to
understand what's actually going on
is this a money laundering scheme i mean
what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean like is this a
famous artist who made this
uh yes actually okay name was beeple
right people
oh poor donald trump
donald trump's corpse laid out in a park
loser eat [ __ ] bye bye
bye bye but what are you supposed to do
with the art you hang it on your wall
in a digital form like uh that'd be cool
if you could
you know get like a frame have like a
digital
loop i think that's cool
it's one possibility you could do sure
yeah so anyway
we're exploring the weird world of
of uh nfts
and we actually made our own nfts
because we want to cash in
frankly that's all there is to it we
just want to [ __ ] get paid
so we made a coin for each of the crew
we made a and i'll tell you what i'm
just putting out we're selling vape
nation
the video
there's a little excitement little shock
we're selling vape nation
the video guys this is your one
opportunity to buy that video i don't
even know what that means
i don't know what that means but we made
a coin of the vape nation video
so before we get into that there's a few
things i want to talk about
you know this is a drama free episode
don't
don't get too concerned i just want to
say that
james charles is a literal predator he's
working with your public
that's what i want to say like the week
after
he admits on twitter to
exchanging nudes with a
16 year old which by the way isn't the
first time he's done this he literally
apparently this is just all he does is
sex
borderline age people
sister and not just a week later he's
like
hi sisters i made a makeup line with
chipotle
it's like nothing [ __ ] matters
literally nothing changed all this me
too [ __ ] is just [ __ ] nothing
[ __ ] changed
yeah really sad i mean this is just
chutzpah dude you know
and i'll [ __ ] be honest i ordered
chipotle this night it didn't it i
didn't do anything to help it either
i just had a diarrhea literally just
like you
saw dan i was in the toilet for like
[ __ ] 10 minutes or maybe even longer
because i had like this crazy chipotle
diarrhea
and i know that's like a joke like
chipotle i don't know why but it always
happens that i get
diarrhea when i eat chipotle and i'm
sorry that i know that's not a pleasing
image
but it's the truth
and the truth shall set you free
i guess it's the hot sauce do you guys
have that problem with chipotle oh every
time every
every time it's like what is going on
with the food there
it burns your butthole it's just it must
be the hot sauce right
i don't have that problem but i don't
have hot sauce
i think it's that red hot sauce just
burns it man
yo you know how they start giving
influencers like their their chipotle
order like david dobrik has one and
apparently james charles says
what's his that's probably disgusting
let's see
well what does it mean to have a
chipotle order it's all the same it's
all the [ __ ] same
there's only like three things to get
there okay
[Music]
so unique i like wok uh i like
just a little bit of guac and a little
bit of beans
lots of rice it's okay shut up james go
order my own [ __ ] let's get glam
um yeah if i if i got my chipotle order
it would just be like
rice and um 10 cups of red hot sauce
just rice and hot sauce it's called the
diarrhea
i need some preparation h after that
that's what makes it special instead of
a diet coke it comes with preparation h
comes with uh what's the pink [ __ ]
yeah it comes with a small bottle of
pepto-bismol to chase it down with
that's ethan's order anyway nothing
matters
james is like an actual [ __ ] predator
on youtube
and nothing matters i don't know what
else i can wow sister snapped like if
anyone gets
deserves to be canceled on youtube it's
david he's a predator he has this huge
platform i'm sorry
james i meant james i'm sorry if anyone
deserves to be canceled
it's james charles he's a little
predator that spends every night [ __ ]
sexting with minors
allegedly sister
um he's a he's a creep he's a predator
and he's working with chipotle so
shout out he can't keep getting away
with it
he can i don't know what's
i don't know what to do about it i mean
the guy is an absolute [ __ ] menace to
society bro
so that's all i have to say about that
um
oh you know what's interesting too deaf
noodles posted this
you know he posted this apology like oh
i've got to do better i've got to do
better and
whatever just some so he's been liking
posts
shaming and slamming on the guy that he
this 16 year old he was exchanging nudes
with you believe this [ __ ]
he's liking posts [ __ ] on this kid
that he preyed on didn't think i'd be
saying this
he liked this post didn't think i'd be
saying this but james charles scandal
has gone too far for once and i'm on
james side because about two years ago i
spoke to the same guy
uh who's from palm beach florida he had
me randomly off snapchat one day and
like a regular person i slid on the
storage and asked who he was
yeah whatever the kid was apparently
[ __ ] 13 and this
some random post on twitter is like oh
yeah this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
the 16 year old and james is like yup
it's not my fault
just like this guy's just like i knew
it's not my fault that i sent a
six-year-old picture of my [ __ ]
it's the internet bro people can tell
you whatever the [ __ ] they want
stump [ __ ] i despise him
bro he gives me straight up r kelly
vibes for real
i mean it's just so odd that he's
getting away with it i mean crystalia's
whole career in life is ruined
ruined for doing virtually the same
thing
you know
am i overreacting i mean what do you
guys think throw it to the crew a little
bit here so i'm not sitting in a vacuum
i just think that you know the guy said
he was going to the
authorities he was going to the police
and it did seem pretty cut and dry
and um well why is he getting chipotle
sponsors
uh well you know how these things work
that was probably in the works for a
long time
but i mean it's true why wouldn't it get
pulled you know
i don't know i don't know maybe they
just didn't know about it but i don't
know it's like
it's like let me think here james
charles got cancelled for using
the wrong [ __ ] vitamin and lost like
a million subscribers right
now he's actually admitting to spraying
on children on social media wait using
the wrong vitamin
yeah that was like with the whole tati
[ __ ] she got pissed because he used
like the
[ __ ] sugar bear oh yeah
so he lost a million subscribers for
using the wrong hair vitamin
now fast forward here
and he's admitted to sexting miners
and uh nothing happens nobody gives a
[ __ ]
i'm gonna someone better [ __ ]
whatever you do just don't slip them a
sugar hair vitamin and health career
will be okay
don't you take a seat right over there
yeah thank you chris that's what i'm
saying
so anyone else got an opinion on this
i'm open years i'm curious what you guys
think
go ahead don't be shy now cut the end
show in say something give your opinion
on james charles oh
god but no support here
love me daddy go ahead ab i see you got
something to say
no i'm just yeah i agree it's insane i
mean he lost almost 3 million
subscribers
oh was it three million yeah tatty
situation awesome dude
yeah that's so [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying
this is way worse he admitted he even
[ __ ] wrote an apology tweet admitting
to it and then he's now
liking post saying this kid was asking
for it or
you know more or less i mean is the
difference just that tati has a big
following
and therefore has more clout and even
though her you know
i mean i mean well yeah tati's video
would go like mega [ __ ] viral
yeah you know to the extent that we
talked about it and i never [ __ ] even
heard of her before so
i just think this is a bigger story yeah
true seems like it but again i mean
the kid said he was going to the police
i mean we maybe
hear a big father so but that that's
kind of like a separate
that's like a whole separate thing i
mean if he files a police report god
bless
that would be big news
one other thing with peace and love this
just popped up on my feed literally
right now and i'm cur and i want to get
you guys take this is an old clip of
david
and by the way david who's on the
anti-bullying tour right now
talks about his time in high school
jason says he
faced lots of anti-semitism growing up
horrible things he he mentions like
people used to throw pennies at his feet
and say pick it up jew
call him a dirty jew i sense he's trying
to downplay it but
like as my dad's been through that kind
of [ __ ] growing up and
it's very traumatic i mean you know my
dad growing up
people like he put up like hanukkah
lights this is in the valley right here
in la
and people drew a [ __ ] swastika on
his garage
door so he's like even to this day still
like
no lights he's very anti-lights
but like um anyway just listen to this
um
they call me dirty jew
yeah i was the only jewish kid in the
school shut up yeah
only jewish kid did you get [ __ ] for
that all the time
you walk down the hallway so we just
throw a penny on the ground oh and
everyone would laugh that used to happen
at my school but that's not
[ __ ] that's unless you're like a
sensitive like [ __ ] about it
like it's kind of it's literally just
like so
yeah exactly you want me to go back
listen to this
listen to this one more time only jewish
kid did you get [ __ ] for that
all the time you walk down the hallway
someone just throw a penny on the ground
oh and everyone would laugh that used to
happen at my school too
but that's not [ __ ] that's unless you're
like a sensitive like
[ __ ] about it like okay david
what that sounds like a horrific [ __ ]
uh anti-semitic moment somebody's easy
to describe the moment where someone
threw a penny at his feet
said pick it up jew and everybody's
laughing at him and david goes that's
not [ __ ] unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] about it
does that sound a little twisted to
anyone else it's [ __ ] up dude
it's so absurd that i thought i
misunderstood what i was hearing yeah
it's not and you didn't hear that he's
not referring to
the uh the kids doing it he's referring
to he's referring to jason
he said did you ever get [ __ ] for it he
says he says yes people used to throw
pennies at my feet
and call and tell me to pick it up jill
he's like that's not [ __ ]
what is [ __ ] it's like that's not [ __ ]
unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
which you are right jason you're a [ __ ]
what would be [ __ ] in david's uh yeah i
got some [ __ ] back in the
you know the 40s my whole family got
exterminated he's like now that
okay that might qualify as [ __ ] it may
be yo you're still kind of a [ __ ] for
bringing it up
i don't know what [ __ ] what qualifies
this [ __ ]
if not that all jews like it's kind of
it's literally just like
it's literally i get it i get it i mean
i was able to take it fine it built
character but i know when i tell like
some people that story they're like
that's awful yeah you could tell
that was traumatic and i i've never
faced anti-semitism like that
like firsthand because there was a lot
of jews growing up in my school and
stuff
but my dad did and i can tell that
i mean it sounds horrible it sounds
really very very
uh very very uh negative experience for
sure
i've experienced some anti-semitism tell
me your story zach
uh just the school i went to a lot of
kids would
they viewed it as a joke calling me the
k word you know yeah that's horrible i
was
i've been called that before to my face
and
there was one time i punched the kid in
the chest for saying it there you go it
was like he said it so many times and
it's like what does my religion have to
do with anything you know yeah i use i
got called a k word once and threw hands
when i was a kid he bitched out and
claimed he didn't know what it meant but
i was like [ __ ]
you know what the [ __ ] it meant it's
it's hard it's not it's not a
you know it's [ __ ] up yeah there was a
good amount of in my schools growing up
too
um and same situation as you ethan i
mean i grew up in an area with a lot of
jewish people and i mean it was still
present
it always it always was i mean
nobody got beat up for being jewish or
anything like that
but um certainly you know jew jokes and
kind of more along the lines of what
jason was describing i mean i feel like
that throwing a penny at your feet and
saying pick it up not me
i feel like i'm like a stealth you
nobody knew that i was jewish but but
there was definitely uh
there's definitely that kind of stuff
going on yeah that to me
seems like extraordinarily aggressive
anti-semitism it's like
i don't know i i hate to depend on this
solely but i
i do feel like the when we were kids
south park was really popular
and like jew jokes was like a huge thing
on that show at least
i don't i haven't watched south park in
years i don't know if they still make
jew jokes all the time
but that was like a thing on there a bit
older though he's like
oh that's remember he's old as [ __ ] yeah
he was probably in high school i know
you're all right
you're right yeah
i was only arab at my school um the only
one
i was the only one yeah and but it was
like after 9 11 there was a lot of like
terrorist jokes and whatnot but
it didn't bother me too much but my
younger brother got teased bad
like they'd call him like smelly arab
and stuff like that right man what the
[ __ ]
yeah yeah afternoon tell your brother
stop being a whiny little [ __ ] [ __ ]
and just
stop being an insensitive [ __ ] no
you're living
i can't believe he said that i mean like
bro what
i'm you walk down the hallway so we just
throw a penny on the ground
oh and everyone would laugh that used to
happen at my school too
but that's not [ __ ] that's unless you're
like a sensitive like [ __ ] about it
like it's kind of it's how is that not
[ __ ] what is [ __ ]
like stabbed did you get stabbed i don't
know what what you what means
literally just like literally i get it i
get it i mean i was able to take it fine
it built character but i know when i
tell like some people that story they're
like that's
awful i know but i know in my school
that [ __ ] happened all the time
right and it wasn't a problem at all
like whether you were you sure it wasn't
a problem
i wonder who was doing it yeah exactly
are you sure it wasn't a problem are you
just like a normal [ __ ] caucasian
white dude that doesn't get
made fun of i mean look at his videos he
shits on everybody he doesn't get any
[ __ ]
he shits on everybody everybody gets
[ __ ] on they're [ __ ] they're fat
they're stupid they're black he doesn't
get any [ __ ]
yeah if you know read between the lines
there a little bit i have a feeling
i know who was making the two jokes
david don't break high school keep
listening here
jewish catholic completely nobody gets
made up for being catholic
i mean in some places catholics get [ __ ]
it's definitely not a thing in
california because there's
never catholics here oh catholic it's
like sorry this isn't the [ __ ]
vatican who makes
what the [ __ ] in a lot of part of the
country catholics are are not
very common wait we live here there's
lots of hispanic people they're all
catholic like
catholic is very normal in california
but in a lot of the country
uh catholics are what do you say about
it
hey you white [ __ ] norm kind of like
normal christian dude
well a lot of catholics are aren't white
though that's the thing
right okay so maybe i'm talking out of
turn here
uh shout out to the catholics it's
catholic
completely white you would get [ __ ]
equally are you completely white dude
you're gonna get [ __ ] equal
so it hasn't changed at all in 20 years
like so people still do that
no one was safe yes of course really now
it's changing now
at least from the internet the internet
is one of the most sensitive places on
earth
so i don't know if that's changing in
schools too but like i know where i grew
up it was i mean you
you can say brandon told me the same
thing brandon we were about the same age
as brandon and he said in his school
oh yeah uh in california that it was the
same no no it was
still brutal no i mean like i know
teachers that would make
you dirty chew jokes like because it's
just what it's not
bad they're just words and like i think
bro
how the [ __ ] are you a normal straight
white
dude gonna come here and tell me words
are just it's just
words maybe that's how we were raised
we're like
they're not you had a teacher that told
a jew joke we had
really cool teachers oh my god this dude
this is a really bad clip this is brutal
and
my dude he's on the anti-bullying tour
right now right
oh man he's saying his favorite
his favorite the coolest teachers are
the ones [ __ ]
the anti-semitic ones are the coolest
ones holy [ __ ]
i [ __ ] kind of am starting to despise
him i think he's just
kind of a piece of [ __ ] he seems pretty
scummy i mean
i like what he's saying about everybody
gave everybody [ __ ]
like i you know that was kind of the
case in my school too i i get what he's
saying there but only hold that
perspective when you're the one doing
the bullying
right if you've ever been on the
receiving end of bowling
you would not come out here with the
perspective of it's all good
no everybody gets [ __ ] oh why would you
even complain it's just words it doesn't
mean anything like
you wouldn't [ __ ] say that if you are
actually ever bullied
yes yes like i got bullied a decent
amount and
yeah you know in fact you would probably
only say that to in
a way to [ __ ] rationalize the amount
of bullying you did
oh no they're fine yeah cynical
they're fine i'm fine so they're fine
somebody called me a white white once
someone called me a cracker once
did it hurt my feelings
so they must be fine that i called them
dirty jews
and threw pennies at their feet pick up
the penny jew
you'd have to be an [ __ ] to be
offended by that
hey jew here's your lucky day i'm
throwing a nickel
hey jew happy friday here's a quarter
pick it up
hey yeah i mean you could tell i love my
teachers
yeah you had some cool ones we did we
went back to david's school none of
those teachers would say stuff like that
but we had really laid-back teachers
where they would
i mean i told you a story where a
teacher once let me go get wendy's
during the class
period because he was annoyed of me
because he was frustrated he was
frustrated he was like get out of my
room and i'm like can i leave the school
and he's like i don't care
just please leave the room and i got in
my car and i drove away
and i came back and i brought him a
sandwich and we were all good the next
day got some got some wendy's she shot
an outro
call me woke but i don't think teachers
should be making anti-semitic jokes
towards their students
call me old-fashioned though yeah i
didn't have any of those teachers in my
school
anyway hope he's having a good time on
the no bullying tour
what a douche
um okay that's that
nothing more to say about that and
that's all i have to say about that
is that the show thanks for watching
everybody that was my forrest gump
jenny i may not be a smart man
but i do know how to wipe my own ass
you think forrest wiped his own ass
probably
yeah he probably didn't do a good job
though you know what i mean
he probably had a shitty [ __ ] forrest
gump and probably
he probably didn't do a thorough wiping
are you guys want to talk nfts this is
the big moment
uh we just got a few minutes to break uh
do we have maybe a short thing we can
well let me show you so
so let me show you some stuff to give
you an idea of how ridiculous this is
too mad for example youtuber fellow
youtuber
selling titty he's selling one of his
left titty one of his right titty
okay here let's see what the current bid
on these are
okay there's just a photo of left it
right it okay
let's see does that no
does that say the bit is at five the bid
is at ten nine thousand dollars okay
this is not a joke
this photo of his tit is going for nine
thousand dollars
do you understand what i'm saying this
doesn't make sense
i get that it's funny but this is real
money this is nine thousand dollars as
well
like someone [ __ ] explained this to
me because i don't get it does he have
it uh
those are those are bids or does he just
set the price at 9000. no it's a bid
wow bam oh somebody's paying top dollar
wait i thought someone was bidding
he sold well when you his initial post
it was at
0.5 so it's definitely gone up yeah it's
a bid yeah
yeah so i mean great for him
but like this is the kind of stuff i'm
seeing every day
so why are people so happy to spend
their their
how do you say this [ __ ] ethereum
ethereum yeah
why are people so happy to spend their
ethereum on dumb [ __ ] because they
people i guess really think these nfts
are worth something
are ntfs whatever the [ __ ] it's called
non-fungible nft
nft yeah ian for example is selling
yeah idubbbz is selling which i can't
show obviously because it's just an
image of his nut sack very disgusting to
be honest
it's really gross it's it's a
image of his nut sack from and then
there's a light behind it so you can see
the veins and stuff
and it's pulled like paper tight
and um it's currently going for fourteen
hundred dollars
a lot less than the than two minutes two
well hold on now
give it some time
yeah i guess he did only post it a
couple days ago
you know give it some time
so you guys want to see our tokens or
not yet
let's save the big reveal for uh after
the break give him a little ski
give him a little peek okay there's a
little bit we have a lot
to talk about here we got some [ __ ]
tokens up in this [ __ ]
i'm gonna i'm on the i feel like i'm on
the um
i'm on the big connect side of selling
i'm gonna make so much money right now
from you [ __ ] sucks i'm gonna be
straight up
big good night
i swear to god people buying this [ __ ]
are just money laundering there's no
other explanation
so like they win we win you know okay uh
just to clarify on two meds uh titties i
just pulled it up the uh
the five ethereum i i think is a a
buyout price
right so that's that's like you know ten
thousand it's close to ten thousand
though currently
see i just don't think that that's uh
wow bid
i think it looks like the top actual bid
is 1.5
right now okay so yes but that's still
quite a bit
that's that is still quite a bit 1.5
that's in fact no uh
it's sold oh it's sold it's old at 1.5
and then the guy that he sold it to
relisted it for five
that's what's going on i'm looking at
the price history right now
he's reselling he's reselling the titty
for five let's [ __ ]
go so he paid 1.5 ethereum which yeah i
guess is about three grand
and then uh a day later relisted it for
maybe i'm being short-sighted but can
you imagine in like 20 30 years maybe
[ __ ] 100 years that
do you don't think left and right titty
gonna be worth some money so
first of all too mad he's gonna be very
upset that you said that
well and second i'd love to matt i come
out here and rep his merch i just
i just it's a commentary on nft i gotcha
um
yeah and also uh so he he's smart he's
um dan can you show yourself why you why
are you not on camera
you're sitting here you're talking yeah
show yourself
why are you just gonna show me sitting
here it's so awkward okay fine
uh and good luck thank you thank you
donald
um yeah he's uh he said he's gonna lose
uh the weight like the titties are going
away
oh so that is this is part of the
incentive right is the last living
memory
right i'm excited to share our our coins
with you guys though they're pretty
[ __ ] epic
they're freaking epic freaking epic now
all right let's take a break and then
we'll come back and we'll introduce our
coins and we'll talk about
nfts and all this [ __ ] and we'll uh have
some fun okay
thank you to stamps.com
let's face it taking trips to the post
office is probably not how you want to
be spending your time
that's why i always recommend mailing
and shipping online with stamps.com
stamp.coms allows you to mail and ship
anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters
packages and you're gonna pay a lot less
with the discounted rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com
saves businesses thousands of dollars
and thousands of
hours and tons of money with stamps.com
you get the services of the post office
and ups
all in one place plus you get the big
ass discounts mailing
with mailing and shipping rates boom
stamps.com you get a 40 off
the post office rates and up to 62
percent off ups rates do you say
something dan
i was just saying up to 40 up to up to
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters
stamps.com it's a no-brainer folks it's
saving you time
and money it's no wonder nearly 1
million small businesses
already use stamps.com
i love stamps.com i use it i mean it's
just like they say it's easy
you don't have to go to the post office
there's a hassle driving parking yada
yada yada
waiting in lines just you know
especially in this day and age i don't
want to see anyone for any reason
my girlfriend uses it for her business
and she loves it exactly
it's a no-brainer um you know it's
easy as pie and you get better prices i
mean what more is there to say
stop wasting time going to post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with
my promo code h3 you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free
postage and a digital skill
free postage wow
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in h3 that's
stamps.com
promo code h3 stamps.com never go to the
post office
again
[Music]
you know that credit card the one you're
afraid to look at because you're afraid
of what the balance is
well if you've been avoiding your debt
it's time to confront it
and upstart can help you face and
finally pay it off
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed monthly payment upstart finds
smarter rates with trusted partners
because they assess more than just your
credit score
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate
up front for loans from one thousand to
fifty thousand dollars
you can get approved the same day and
receive funds as fast as one
business day later if debt is taking
over your life
it's time to get a fresh start with
upstart find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payment today
when you go to upstart.com h3 that's
upstart.com
h3 don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you
appreciate you on that loan amount will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
one more time go to upstart.com h3
oh we're back thank you for everybody's
sticking around appreciate that
um there's one other thing speaking of
david dobrik and anti-semitism this was
a fun story that came out
uh who's this guy mayors liam what the
[ __ ]
mayer's leonard leonard
yeah it's his last name kind of a weird
last name leonard
oh thank you that makes more sense
leonard
sometimes do you ever get surprised but
just how dumb you are
like sometimes i'll be like trying to
spell specifically i'm really bad at
spelling
or sounding out a word something and i
i'm like
i just have to put the pen down and walk
away and be like
you are so [ __ ] dumb i just lose
faith in myself
you know thank you but do you guys ever
have like that because i feel like i
have that all the time i don't know no
never
well there's a psychological study that
associates being genius with
uh bad spelling that's true
there is i swear to god i'm a terrible
speller too so that means i feel like
most smart people i know are good
spellers
thank you thank you baby no problem i'm
not going to make me feel smart
can we talk about abe and zach both
dying their hair blonde and dress yeah i
think it's fantastic and i'm [ __ ] and
i'm ashamed
i'm embarrassed that ian first of all
will not bleach his beard for me
what about dad and i'll dance next
let me see your hair you said you're
gonna bleach your hair let me see can
you take the beanie off let me see
what's happening i haven't bleached it
no i said i'd consider it i just want to
see what you're working with before
i have a mullet you do
yeah i've got some sick ass hair dude
i feel like if you bleached your beard
and dan
show your bleach your beard that would
be
i'm not gonna do it pretty gang gang not
gonna do that that's weird
yeah it's it's cool though no no i don't
know
all right about that i'm talking about
that dome
but yeah ab and zach thank you guys for
bleaching in solidarity although
abe really abe's hair looks good like he
was like he did tuner and the purple
shampoo and all this [ __ ]
well they're wearing the denim too
they're like they're copping the whole
look
yeah yeah you see my hair doesn't look
bro
mine doesn't look good
it looks it looks well
his looks like he tried a lot harder you
know what i mean
to make it look good this isn't my first
rodeo i've been blonde before so i know
okay i know what i'm doing there's a lot
of frizz going on there exactly
like yeah it looks like you bleached
your hair and that's fine
you know i did three bleaches and toned
it
yeah how'd your hair feel you did it
three times does your hair feel like hay
yeah it's [ __ ] atrocious i thought it
would get a little more
like you know like you know ex natural
hair is dark too
in his defense so it's harder for him
okay can we talk about anti-semitism
sure
so this guy goes this guy had a heated
gamer moment
who's this guy maynard lee uh leonard is
he a good is he like a big player
i don't think so oh really for uh miami
who was in the finals last year
oh so he's he's pretty famous but he's
like
he's a am i wrong isn't he like a backup
player or something he's not uh i mean
he's not like their marquee guy
right anyway this guy comes out there
and he goes
he's like yo i am a professional nba
player but it's not enough i gotta get
on twitch and have
a heated gamer moment playing cod watch
this
let's go baby
[Music]
he knew he [ __ ] up right kind of
sounded like a little bit about
change to change the subject it has
really it gives me bridge vibes like
hardcore beautified fridge vibes
just he's a gamer moment through and
through you know what i mean
because pewdiepie knew he [ __ ] up
right afterwards too same thing uh
same oh wait no it wasn't that was pub g
yeah that's not the same game
dude if anything makes you that mad that
you start blurting out racial slurs
don't play it
right all jews is that a good rule of
thumb
faze clan said i don't know why the [ __ ]
phase is even making a statement
he's an investor apparently part owner
so what does it mean when you cut ties
with investor you give him his money
back and tell him to [ __ ] off
yeah you buy him out huh sounds like a
good deal
man if i was trying to get a payout from
faze i'd be dropping n bombs everywhere
we were incredibly disappointed to hear
uh meyer's stream today faze does not
tolerate hate speech or
discriminatory language of any kind
while mayer's is not a member of phase
we are cutting ties with him
i'm cutting ties with him too while
we're at it this community has so much
going to do let's be better together
well you could start by like
[ __ ] getting rid of some of your
phase members who like are
literal human scum but
well here you go they face up bro
they're phasing them out
i i'm here i'm announcing today that i'm
cutting ties
although i have no association with him
at all we have a lot of growing to do
and so i am cutting ties with him
bye-bye there's a clip of him getting a
call from his wife can you
can you happen to find that during he
keeps playing the game like nothing
happened and his wife
calls him and he's like oh [ __ ]
that was a good gamer moment as well
let's go
[ __ ] cowards don't [ __ ] snag me
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i just dropped
david's like you'd have to be a [ __ ] to
find that offensive
you'd have to be the biggest [ __ ] in
the world to find that offensive
uh the here's some kind of press release
that dan was saying he loves
i haven't read this social team's been
reading
what oh is this him yeah and i just love
the image that they chose
wait he really chose this well not him
personally but yeah this was
uh this is an official statement they're
trying to make it look like a heated
gamer moment
i am deeply sorry for using an
anti-semetics third during a live stream
yesterday that's it
i guess what more is there to say all
jews
you know those [ __ ] glasses not him
playing basketball just him having a
heated game
with his gamer glasses on i threw in
that call from his wife
in the doc yeah this is pretty good so
the guy keeps playing like nothing
happens [ __ ] cowards don't [ __ ]
yo literally why does it look like
20 year old latency video let's go baby
[ __ ] cowards don't [ __ ] snipe me
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] with a lot of gusts i just jumped
out on my head didn't even go to [ __ ]
um anyways let's go
[ __ ] there comes the call from his
life
hey dude i just got a call from your
manager yeah you just ruined our [ __ ]
lives
thanks bro enjoy twitch hope you get a
good game of cod
so anyway i'm taking the kids i want a
divorce
you ruined our lives i'm gonna sue you
for everything you have
i hope you have a lot of people watching
on twitch because that's basically all
you're gonna have left is what she's
saying i don't know
uh my wife went out for pizza without me
[ __ ] hate you
you're a piece of [ __ ] he goes
yo my wife needs me she just called me
i'll uh i gotta roll brother
ggs okay hey did you buy that what do
you think gigi's brother
that's pretty epic i gotta say this guy
just got [ __ ] chad something came out
i gotta um
go hang with my wife um
really dude
[Music]
wake up this should be his avatar on
twitter and [ __ ] and instagram
yeah so that was fun all right let's
talk about so anyway yeah that's
everything you know we're all caught up
in the news
that's what i'm here to do i think i
don't know i don't know why i'm here you
guys
i'm here to sell you some [ __ ] nfts
all right let's talk about nfts well ian
you've been working on this for a while
what do you think about nfts
i've read a lot a lot of days on it and
i still don't really get it
i don't fully understand i don't know
zack was trying to explain it about mona
lisa or something
what does zach know about nfts with
peace and love
i was just reading up that um they're
comparing it to
tulip mania which was a um
art trend in the uh past centuries
of people drawing tulips and it just
turned into this huge
art movement i don't know what that has
to do with the mona lisa i i gave the
mona lisa analogy
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what you guys
tulip mania tell me tell me more about
tulip mania
people were selling tulips for a bunch
of money well no no it was drawings of
tulips
and um it just they went for a lot of
money
and they started to sell and resell and
it was a big thing does any has anyone
heard of tulip mania
uh i have i i think that uh with peace
and love zach you're you're
totally misunderstanding what it was
tulip mania was appeared during the
dutch golden age
and it's generally to be considered the
first bubble
oh the first bubble the tulip bubble
yeah
so you're just saying we're in a bubble
i think the nft thing is
i don't think it had anything to do with
art or or
or any uh we're in a tulip bubble come
on dan don't burst this bubble on this
one what did tulip meaning had to do
with art
you just said drawings of tulips you
said tulip mania is you're using the
tulip mania to explain the nft
yeah because it's a bubble yeah
this is the most i've ever seen ian left
since i think i've worked for you guys
no zach he sounds really smart it's
wrong
he sounds like a guy that doesn't know
how to spell which is it just
yeah exactly
you guys want me to explain the mona
lisa thing yeah go ahead but i'm i'm
just fascinated by the two
i want to talk about tools yeah i want
to talk about tulips go ahead ap let's
talk about i'm trying to i'm trying to
help
that guy oh i just read up that the
analogy of a lot of people are saying
what's so impressive about nft is what's
the value in it
and the mona lisa example was you could
print off a picture of the mona lisa or
you can you know
download a picture of it or get a poster
of it but it's not the original
mona lisa so people are saying nfts
the value is the ownership because
you're owning the original
well you're just you're explaining
ownership but i mean
everyone has a physical body where you
could put it on your wall you could put
it in a museum you could touch it you
could feel
it it has a direct link to the person
who painted it it has brush strokes
you could see the expression the person
you know what i mean like
i feel like that is
a shallow comparison yeah no i'm not
saying i agree but i guess in terms of
value
although if you look at digital art it
makes sense
right like for example the let's say
the um we talked earlier about the
neon cat meme sold for hundred thousand
dollars here we'll be pulling up
this gift you guys remember this [ __ ]
so the author sold this for i guess they
sold it for 600 000
what does that mean that they sold it
though so somebody owns this gift now
no so that's confusing to me okay so
let me give you let me give you the the
nft rundown
as i understand it and i'm sure lots of
crypto people will be in the comments
saying dang you're an idiot and you
don't understand so i apologize in
advance
basically all the nft thing is here let
me put the camera on myself so you don't
get triggered
uh the nft yes deplete the cat while i
gotta sit here just looking like a
[ __ ] idiot
thank you okay so the nft thing
basically
all it is is using uh blockchain
technology as a way
of creating a um non-counterfeitable
uh proof of ownership
that can be sold and transferred around
now
what that means is like once you create
a an nft token
and you insert say like a piece of art
or a song or some sort of like asset
that it's attached to you're able to
prove that this is a unique
version of that asset so in the example
of the nyankat
gif this one the original creator of it
didn't actually sell the gift the person
that bought the nft
doesn't own the gift what they own is a
version of that gif
that has been signed and
minted by the creator so i think it's a
coin
i think the best comparison that you can
make
is really it's an autograph right it's
like it's like a uh
it's getting a verified autograph from a
creator
and doesn't necessarily have to be what
do you call that a really high when you
like really high quality
copy they do have art all the time
uh it is similar to that yeah or like
when a photographer an artist
sells a limited edition lot of money you
know what i mean right because of their
rarity and because they've authenticated
and they're authentic and they're
they're made by
this artist and so yeah that that's the
best way to think about it
is you're not actually selling the
underlying asset i guess you could but
that's a whole different thing
you theoretically could and in some
cases uh as we'll probably discuss or
maybe
we can bring it up now so most
people are aware of the artist banksy
very famous kind of uh
anonymous uh street artist uh who
doesn't
why am i staring at myself oh my god and
um
he uh he just recently sold one of these
uh do you guys remember how much
i think we got it yeah banksy sold a
mother
loving uh 180k
380 000. so he sold but what he did
is he burned the original
copy of this piece of art and now
the the nft version of that
uh of that art is what still exists is
one of one exactly
right this is banksy no it's just some
kid i was like what the [ __ ]
okay so here here it is there here's the
burning ceremony
now this is an interesting thing so they
take this bank 2006
here's the original banksy piece they
digitized it put it online as an nft
and they destroyed the original so the
only real version
but it's still kind of confusing because
it doesn't even mean anything because
there's still
images of this [ __ ] painting online
right and that's the thing is that and
he doesn't the the buyer of this doesn't
own
the the copyright or the ip or anything
no
so i'm kind of confused by the whole
what they own
is a copy of this painting a digital
version of this painting
sign essentially
signed by the artist the problem here
that i have is like
you it has a physical body which is
being destroyed
right the owning a digital version is
not a replacement for
having a physical copy of it like even a
lithograph
would be more useful than a [ __ ]
digital copy i guess you could re
you could reprint it right well the
value is coming from the scarcity right
from the fact that there's only one of
these nfts this
this kind of digital representation of
this
signed by banksy in existence and so
if you want that you know uh there's
some price that you could theoretically
attach to that
well clearly someone sees the value
because they paid 380 thousand dollars
for it
right and as you uh kind of previewed
earlier there's the the
the people piece that sold for like six
million or something like that
that's so here here's another one this
[ __ ] is crazy
this one makes more sense to me because
it is digital art you know so like
you're owning it in its original form
so here's what again you don't actually
own the art though well okay let me ask
you this when you buy
let's say you bought the mona lisa okay
right
you still don't own the ip you own the
original piece but you don't own the ip
uh you know i don't really know how that
works
um you can't license out the mona lisa
just because you own the physical
painting of it well uh something that
old is in public domain okay it's just
an example
but it's a bad example because mona
lisa's okay but
bro i'm just saying uh using an example
of a more recent piece of art that isn't
public domain
would be a better comparison
[ __ ] you dan i'm sorry dan i know that
okay let's say a scribble a picture of
my dick on a [ __ ] piece of paper and
i said all right
i'm gonna sell this to dan for a million
dollars
that does that i don't think that means
that you can go license the shirt with
that picture on it now
right correct and that's yeah when
somebody buys an nft they are not buying
the copyright to
the original piece unless that's somehow
included
in what's being sold but in the vast
majority of cases that is not
uh what's happening this yeah cat thing
again the the original creator of the
nan cat
still owns the cat so this is the one by
this artist people who i guess i'm not
familiar with him but he's
he's pretty famous yep he designed this
digital
gif i guess or whatever video loop
slideshow
yeah um first
he broke the record i think oh this was
the secondary market so i wonder how
much
how much of the original sold for oh it
was resold
it says here it resold on secondary
market for 6.6 million
goddamn 6.6 who's got money to just
throw around like that
million dollars that's what i'm saying
it doesn't add up there's some kind of
money laundering thing going on here
well the art world is notorious for uh
being an avenue for money laundering so
that might actually be true
but who's to say the money laundering
thing is like if you
somebody actually paid 6.6 the
or how does the money laundering work
it's like you sell to your friend for 6
million and then take a six million
right off
uh yeah because yeah it
art the art world is very common for
money laundering things because art
doesn't have really a set price it's
very
you know in the eye of the beholder kind
of thing
and so it's um pretty notorious for
being used that way yeah
what am i gonna do so anyway this is 6.6
million can anyone find how much the
original sold for
i'm looking right it's probably on the
blockchain
you can probably go look it up somewhere
wherever it was sold
i mean it's nice but it's i don't know
six million nights a lot of cheddar
cheese yeah
let's go to this website nifty gateways
this is one of the ones where they're
selling originally purchased for a 66
k when did that happen
on november 1st and then it resold for 6
million
that's what i'm saying in this article
man that artist is [ __ ] sweating
right now so
excited that doesn't make sense who
would buy it for that much more
there's something shady going on with
these nts bro
nfds nft is what i know this guy killer
acid
he's selling some yeah a lot of artists
are getting on board with it um
yeah i've seen artists making a lot of
money from this [ __ ] which is great
it is fairly controversial in the art
world though i've seen a lot of pushback
from people
um as well so not everybody's so on
board with it but yeah i mean
you know a lot of people see it as a way
for artists to reliably make money
which is nice and obviously art gets
stolen all the time and
i think the the fact that this is uh
a way to sell things in a verifiable way
you know what you're getting isn't
counterfeit in some ways
i've seen these artists becoming like
millions like they were selling their
art for like
five hundred five hundred a thousand two
thousand now they're selling their [ __ ]
for like
because like ten thousand twenty
thousand dollars per piece it is just
well i was giving zach some [ __ ] about
the tulip thing earlier but um
but it was mostly because he was calling
it drawings that it is comparable to
that in that it was
it's likely a speculative bubble i think
right now people
don't really fully understand what well
they are what they're even buying
in on this [ __ ] bubble right now
that's what we're here to do i'm here
to get paid plain and simple i don't
understand it
i don't think that there's really
necessarily value in this but but maybe
you understand it better than me because
here's what i'm going to tell you guys
right now
as i open up our very special
one of a kind here yes baby
wow that's how i feel right now
so here is six one of a kind
this is the only time these will ever go
on sale
these are limited edition authentic
wait you keep saying one of a kind i
thought they're i thought there's more
than one they're not one of a kind
actually
one of them is one of them one of them
is one of a kind yes so let me introduce
you guys one
basically here first of all let me but
what i'm saying is these will never be
minted again
anything doesn't doesn't sell will be
immediate destroyed after what do we
what do we think like two weeks we
didn't even decide two weeks a month
two weeks is plenty a month baby let's
[ __ ] sell this [ __ ] baby
two weeks two weeks yeah
so here is the vape nation coin now each
crew member is getting their own coin uh
just
just it's a token not a coin
oh and the distinction please uh
within the uh crypto terminology they
they are distinct things uh
what's it to what's a token well it's
it's part of the fact that this is an
nft non-fungible token
as opposed to a coin which is used it's
fungible
um it's meant to be right right right
right let me just say by the way they're
trying to get these
up on the website for you guys to buy
with such pain in the ass we had to use
crypto
to like pay the website we tried it from
three different
like we tried it three different ways
it's just the whole idea that crypto
being a currency just seems so odd to me
like
the the value fluctuates so much on a
day-to-day basis
and when we're trying to actually use it
to buy something it's taking us like
hours to get it done it's just i don't
see the convenience yeah um
but i mean look it seemed like the
networks were uh
having trouble today because um uh
there's like a big trading
no it doesn't have network troubles a
piece of [ __ ] paper
thank you i rest my case what am i gonna
do
this has been a great sales pitch so far
hey well listen i'm i'm i'm counting on
these guys knowing more than me
you all got to believe in it more than i
do
you know i'm just hoping i get paid
you know so this is the h3h3
vape nation five year anniversary token
this is the only time i will ever make a
token
here on the fifth year anniversary of
vape nation
vape nation this is a
highly collectible sought after token
as it is um uh
i don't know it's just i don't know it's
a gif i don't know what you do with it
but apparently it's valuable
we made 250 because i'm hoping that
there's enough suckers out there to buy
this
the price is one ethereum so that means
if if
we sell all these then i would make half
a million bucks is that right i guess
i guess that's right crazy like i'm
gonna [ __ ] eat i'm gonna eat a clump
of
my own hair if we sell all those you
hear me
uh well that's a pretty good incentive
to see you dude yeah half a million
bucks i'd do that i'll eat my own hair
i don't know how i'll have to like cook
in some or something i mean you have to
shave it off and then
prepare it like a bowl of ramen right
that would be fitting
oh with some seasoning soy sauce oh i
don't know if i'll be able to put that
down
i'll try though that's puke city right
there so there's 250 coins whatever is
not sold
uh will be destroyed in the bin this
will be the one and only time to get
your
your um vape nation collectible token
actually i will say with peace and love
listen compared to like two met with
peace you know peace and love i've seen
two mads
titty going for like 2 thousand bucks um
idubbbz nut sat going for 1500. we did a
lot we did we worked with cam grants we
were like
talented video artists to make bring you
this
beautiful art this is art i want to put
this on my wall in like a digital frame
this is art and you own it right
exactly you own a copy of it you
right you don't own it no you own a
print of it
signed by me a digital print a digit
[Music]
and it and then like it sits in your
hard drive how do you sits on a website
how do you
where do you own it yeah you own it you
own it on the blockchain
so if you is it like when you lose your
web your hard drive you can
you can lose it forever kind of vibe uh
well
um i think you would likely be able to
recover it in another way that's good
it's yours baby you could yo when you
get
beamed up when singularity happens and
our unconscious gets
[ __ ] consciousness gets transferred to
um the cloud
you could bring this with you that's you
can't bring the mona lisa
you can't can't bring it with you but
you can bring this vape nation
token so that's mine
yeah and this nft stuff you joke but um
one of the other uses aside from art
sales that um
has been getting a lot of hype is using
it for in-game assets
um so you know there's been some
proof-of-concept stuff where people have
been
using like uh i think we put in the dock
about this cryptokitties game
it's kind of like a new age yeah i'm
staring
how hard is it to switch to yourself it
is hard
anyways uh so the with the
this technology they're talking about
using it for say in
world of warcraft or whatever you get um
some mount
um that's cool that'd be worth a lot
right and then you would
you would actually own the mount because
right now in a game
like that you know blizzard the company
behind it
really owns everything like you're
you're you know they can ban you at any
time
you don't have any recourse for that um
so in the future that we may see
more game companies adopting this kind
of technology where when you get
something in the game uh you
actually own it um and you don't
transfer it
you're going into video games maybe you
can flex your your nfts
in the [ __ ] game right yes they
already have virtual watch parties of
the h3 podcast
and vr so imagine hanging one yeah they
have vr
watch parties who's doing that what are
they doing
i seen that on discord yeah someone just
told me about it and then there's like
people sitting where is it happening
i'm not sure which game the cloud baby
hey guys hi to the virtual watch party
we love you
somebody buy this [ __ ] token and put
it up on your wall in your virtual house
you may be able to yeah okay so that's
my coin
there's a lot of that one because all
because they're you know
um i don't know why but there's 250 that
one
okay moving on to um now here let me
explain
each of the crew members has their own
token
same rarity same limited dish in nature
all the proceeds are going to go to that
so if you love one of these guys and you
want to buy one of these they're getting
all that cheddar cheese okay
oh we have a picture of the virtual
watch party let me open this
i see one person
hey dude if you want the nft you can buy
it to the one dude watching this
virtually
shout out to you though we love you so
this is um
so what do we have five for each for
each crew there's only
five that is so rare you guys that is
unbelievably rare can you imagine if you
owned like an original picasso
five of five lithograph that would be
worth what like a million dollars easily
yeah if it was a picasso although
according to um the current prices
if only picasso would just burn one of
his lithographs and mint it it'd be
worth like 100 billion dollars true
anyway you were alive to do that this is
um
a b super simple five coins
this is so epic it's him on the gatsby
hitting that vape name
and then transforming super saiyan super
simpin
505. if you want to support a b you
better buy one of these tokens
he's gonna be rich after this you think
you're gonna sell any of these baby
uh hopefully how many do you think
um one i think one would be optimistic
but how much do you think you'll sell
all of them no i said one would be
optimistic
hopefully yeah you think you saw one i
think you saw one
possibly i'm so excited we gotta talk to
we have to figure out who buys these and
talk to them because i'm
i want to be like why did you buy this
if they'll if they're willing to come
forward you know what i mean
i want to know what the [ __ ] how many of
these you guys think i'm gonna sell of
250 maybe like three
i think you're going to sell all of them
i think i think you're devaluing it
by selling so many well
sold 3 000 of his dumb ass [ __ ]
pokemon
okay well we didn't talk about logan
paul but i think the reason logan
paul did so well with this aside from
the fact that there's a lot of hype
around this stuff right now
is that he uh had a
essentially a contest going on where if
you bought one you had
a chance to get one of those uh first
edition pokemon
boxes unopened which is worth a ton of
money he sold like over 2
000 at one ethereum he made like three
and a half million dollars in one day
selling some dumbass
yeah a little piece of art paul pogba
right which our vape nation art
is way cooler yeah but when you buy this
vape nation art
he was giving away two packs to like 2
000 people nobody's entering that
those packs are worth like 50 grand but
i'm saying he made 3.5 million dollars
you give away
he gives away what's a lottery i mean
it's the same as the david thing
those odds are horrible though still
better than that who's gonna throw away
two thousand dollars for a chance to win
some dumbass pokemon well that's
that's a mother freaking blueberry
that's the quest that's the three and a
half million dollar question isn't it
who who's buying this stuff well i'm not
giving away anything but
the coin itself mucho broken though
this is the real value right here anyway
i think we'll sell like three of these
perhaps three of those one of the a b
here's dan's of course
dan is you've got five of these dan you
want to explain this
yeah i mean i was asked like everybody
else what
i would like mine to be and i i find
this whole thing to be uh pretty silly
and kind of
a scam so um i've got a bridge i can
sell you
dan has a bridge he can sell you i do
like how it turned out though
yeah it does look great i like zuck uh
how zuck kind of
scoots by there i think dan's gonna sell
all of these because of the irony of it
i
hope that nobody buys these and there's
a sale thing blowing in the wind
he's got a bridge to sell you for only
two thousand dollars
i think you'll sell one or two of those
dan don't buy this
no they'll buy it damn what are we doing
here no buy it
listen the h3 audience grows every day
this is a one-time chance
the values may go up i just want to say
i i wanted it to be set to bid
and like start at like one cent and just
let it be like an auction
but uh how is that better because then
when people start bidding high on it
inevitably then you're gonna look even
dumber
people spend a hundred thousand dollars
on this i don't think it would get that
high that's just
that's my speculation hundred thousand
this would go for if there was no buyout
easy next
miniature baby i think dan wilson sell
two of those i think we got two dans
one a b three vape niches
zax of course joker brain who could who
could um
probably my favorite i might buy this
one
you wouldn't get it apparently i'm half
as close you did
[Applause]
so there you go i mean this i love that
i mean it looks great come on it's it's
a it's a work of art
it truly is i mean this is what we're
selling here we're selling art don't you
understand
this is digital art it doesn't exist you
can't buy this anywhere
this is the only copy you now
this is your one [ __ ] chance there's
only five of these available
this is good art bro i pointed out to
zach earlier but um
he's got to go get a manicure i get
manicures damn his nails are looking
i've seen him
that's what happened i've seen much
worse
you know maybe it's just because it's so
close to the camera but it's just kind
of bugging me what what's your problem
like here
yeah yeah yeah no no not the nail itself
it's the it's so
dry like the hand nail yeah i'm just
saying here let me go back
like this instrument dance do you lube
your fingers
uh zach i mean i i lotion up you do
lotion up
i do listen it was after a session of
playing guitar
well i don't i don't we playing without
a stick yeah dude
okay i mean listen if that one thing of
trump's like corpse in the park
is sold for 6.6 million i don't see any
reason why we can't sell all of these
this is bomb art this is bombard
ian's up next ian's is pretty epic too
ian there's five of these of course and
you want to explain that's promoting
from the matrix
it's me trying to understand nfts and
really i'm just a puppet of the mach
machine
taking over this is [ __ ] awesome art
that you can own there's only five of
these available
this is cooler than trump's corpse for
6.6 million this is a bargain at two
thousand dollars there's only five of
them available
true only five and then this is the most
special one
okay this is one of one okay
this is first of all the legendary vape
god
coin okay so just take this in for a
moment
one of one this one is a bid
there's only one of these available but
that's not all
this is also ownership of the one
and only
vape nation video
how do you explain this uh ian i don't
know how to explain it
[Music]
the video the video will be included
inside of it
so it's the vape god token and
the vape nation uh nft
one of one bro this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity
so this is this is a bid this you cannot
buy this you can only bid on this
what's the uh the starting ask on the
bid where does the bidding begin
did we um i don't know
what's up to you probably one just one
so it starts at the same price as
everything yeah just
one okay okay okay
so this is a prized possession i mean
this is [ __ ] epic brah
can you do fake bids like you remember
when we sold our beanie on ebay and it
got the big got up to like 300 million
dollars
uh that's a good question when you bid
on this site do does
your money go into escrow
like you have to do you have to give the
money up front i hope so
because this is going to turn into a
[ __ ] show i suspect that you do
yeah i suspect so i mean how else could
you do an auction for six point six
million dollars
right you know i don't know some of you
may not remember but we did
like this goof on modern art where we
framed our beanie
and we put it up on ebay
and uh the bidding started going up to
like half a billion dollars
and funnily enough a lot of people
thought it was real they're like aren't
you like a billionaire now
i was like yeah bro i sold it for half a
billion
i think you're going to break that
people record with the babe niche
i'm calling it right now i think this is
going to sell for more than 6.6 million
dollars i think so
i think it's going to break the record
world record i'm going to quit this show
i mean it's more legendary than the
[ __ ] people you know
right i think this is valuable
i mean i mean think about all the money
you can invade paying taxes on
right if you spend a lot on it i think
it's too valuable
i was heavily against including the vape
nation the video
yeah i had to i had to do it you really
want to go along
i had to do it but it does i mean i had
to do it dan
nothing's happening to the original
video well originally i was toying with
the idea of erasing the first one
the original but i i mean that would
actually
yeah that's good that's more akin to
what banksy did where he he
deleted the original in order to the
thing is transfer the values still gonna
be uploads on youtube so i just
again i don't really know what it means
again i
i it's not exactly this but the the way
after reading a lot about it the way
that it finally clicked for me is to
start thinking about it as an autograph
like the way any piece of memorabilia
that has the autograph of somebody
famous you know
the the game-winning baseball or
whatever you know signed by the
winning batter sure but like even if i
like erase the original it's still just
the only autographed version which is
what you're getting
uh correct right right and i i'm
agreeing that if you were to delete
the video off of it didn't need to
destroy his painting
because it's not a replacement for the
painting it's
just an autographed version of it banksy
does all kinds of
you know pretentious statement kind of
stuff like that though so
you know i think he was trying to push
the the concept a little bit further
you know transferring the um the
existence of this painting
fully into a digital asset
well regardless these are the six coins
we have very excited
we're trying to make some we're trying
to make some sales here yeah i want to
make money i mean
but at the same time we can take your
bridge but come on
listen well i said you guys can sell it
for whatever you want and just set mine
to a pen no there's only one bid do not
[ __ ]
step to the vape god token okay you
don't get the bid
the vape got token gets the bid
you have five coins you're gonna miss i
was stepping on your toes
what are the chances we sell all of
these
the fact that you made 250 makes the
chance of selling all of them
zero zero zero you're gonna sell 250 of
them
like you said half a million dollars one
chance they get to own a piece of the
vape
nation history oh my god how many
subscribers do they have across all
channels what are the chances
250 people want to stand out and do the
math dan
the man there's
i want to point out that big connect uh
went down being a scam
so yeah but as long as i get money and
i'm out then i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not baby are you doing like a
stand-up routine now what is it
yeah what's with the what's this what's
the mic what's going on this is my sales
mic
this is my sales oh you're doing like
okay limited edition
first edition by the by the tokens qvc
what the [ __ ] yeah but uh
i think this could be worth something
especially with the rarity of it
we'll see i'm excited to see what
happens i mean
everybody's going to profit off this you
know
everyone's going to be rich i'm kind of
interested to see if like nobody sells
any
like for some reason just nobody buys
zach so that's my brother
you know what i mean well uh zach's
zach's is legitimately so good i love
his
you know or like would i pay two
thousand dollars for that maybe the vape
god only ends up going for like you know
well you're starting the bid at 2k yeah
but if nobody wants to bid 2k someone
could make an offer of like a hundred
right oh so right people can like maybe
they can lowball you yeah they come back
maybe we uh
maybe we never even figure out how to
post them and they just never go
i mean that's a distinct possibility
yeah i mean
this for me on a personal level isn't a
good advertisement for
bitcoin technology or crypto technology
did you get the ethereum in your wallet
yet hey uh ian
cause we've been waiting for hours yeah
it's been
it still hasn't shown up in the wallet
um it's been sort of a nightmare trying
to do this and it's not really a great
uh
it hasn't sold ethan on the technology
let's put it that way listen but
again i please don't [ __ ] hate me if
you have bitcoins i'm sorry just buy or
[ __ ] and you're cool
you're cool dude i don't know what to
say so the link's in the description
we're gonna keep promoting these i think
for two weeks
you know and uh i'm just honestly this
is gonna be a really interesting
experiment to see what happens i am
interested to see
yeah if nobody buys it it's hilarious if
they all sell it
it's [ __ ] awesome everybody's rich
dude we all gotta go to like disney or
some [ __ ] even though it's closed
they're opening back up we should do
something if people buy this [ __ ] i
don't know what
door man if you party i love that guy
dude that's how i feel right now
yes carlos my man
i know how it feels
carlos is such a legend so did he ever
get arrested
is he in jail now no he he didn't
perpetrate any scam he was a victim of
it
oh was he victimized by it yeah he was
just some sap who came on stage and was
like
i love big connect because he thought he
was making much money
i think he just got scammed
uh you all want to talk about
oh dude i gotta talk about this [ __ ] our
boy all gas
no brakes friend of the show andrew
callahan posted this to instagram and i
gotta speak up for him
um you guys know all gas snow breaks he
goes out
interviews people he's a legend he's a
friend of the show
here just in case i'll show you the
youtube channel refresh your memory
this is him
he goes out meets all these weird
characters interviews him i mean he's
the man
his he is like the best content so here
he posted this just the other day
i am no longer associated with all gas
no breaks
i no longer receive any of the patreon
crowdfunding youtube monetization or any
other show
income nick and evan who lived in the rv
with me and created the original show
material are
also no longer involved we have no
control over the accounts or future
of the show when i was 20 i wrote a book
called all gas no breaks about
hitchhiking around america as a teenager
at 21 i pitched the idea for a video
based roadshow to a production company
who loaned me an rv to make videos and
explore america with my best friends
i was ecstatic so i signed an employment
contract without reading it
lesson learned thank you all for
supporting me this past year it's been
the time of my life i can't wait to show
you guys what's next this is not the end
now i haven't spoken to andrew so i
don't know
but i know he's making
working on a video a movie with app so i
know for a fact it wasn't absolute that
screwed him because i saw some people
wondering
it was not absolutely who screwed him
that's good to know because that would
have been very
disappointing to hear so he he had
ownership with
this company i don't remember the name
but they bought right he talked about it
when he came on the show
yeah the lord as i understand it is that
he they bought him an rv
which was probably like five thousand
dollars and took i'm just guessing i
don't know he hasn't told me
but some like huge majority of the show
like
you know 90 or something right or like
between 70 and 90
or something and so
and so like when you go to patreon
you'll notice all gas no breaks has like
a huge patreon page
yeah it's like close to twenty thousand
check there was like seventeen thousand
let me see
bro i think i'm supporting them on
patreon i gotta unfollow
so here's 18 000 people supporting on
patreon and now he's not even getting
any of it before he was getting a small
percentage of it and now
he's getting none of it so they must
have fired him
thinking that they could get a new host
or something because i don't know what
the [ __ ] else they're gonna do
i mean i don't know how to explain it so
if you're
supporting this [ __ ] on patreon i would
recommend turning it off
go on sub i'm gonna turn it on youtube
too you said he doesn't get anything
from you he's out
so he has to go start his his own like a
new original ip and hopefully
i think people will come back because he
is the i mean he
is all guest no breaks yeah such
scumbags dude i [ __ ] hate these
people
they literally gave him like five
thousand dollars and now they want to
own his whole [ __ ] life
and the balls on these people who think
they can replace him
yeah yeah i mean the brand is him
you just unintentionally referred to him
as all gas no brakes like that's
like that's his name that's him yeah
right yeah so i'm gonna i'm actually
gonna turn off my patreon support but i
guess for my boy
i know whatever is gonna be coming out
next is gonna be great so you know we
got his back
and whatever comes out we'll be talking
about here you bet your ass on that
papa john's in the news oh what for
papa why do you do this he was all over
the news papa come
on you've been through so much racial
sensitivity training and you still
dropping bombs like this
first of all papa's why are you doing
interviews on aon of all places
this is when he dropped this [ __ ] way
in
he ready for this [ __ ] and papa with
peace and love i don't i'm not meaning
to do you dirty i'm just covering the
news
this is all a farce well it's you saying
it papa i don't know what's a farce
about it
okay here he is on aon take me back to a
few years ago when you start to see
these headlines coming out and smearing
your good name
how did you feel at the time when you
were seeing these headlines
um state of shock um
unbelievable um i couldn't understand it
i
i mean again you have a public board
that paints its chairman
uh complicit passive or active they
paint
the founder as a racist they know he's
not a racist
it's just unbelievable and i used to lay
in bed just going how did they do this
and we've had three goals for the last
20 months to get rid of this
n-word uh in my vocabulary
and dictionary and everything else so
papa's been working the past 20 months
to get the n word out of his vocabulary
papa
what the [ __ ] does that mean
i gotta hear that again i gotta hear
that again and we've had three goals for
the last 20 months to get rid of this
uh n word uh three goals in the past 20
months that's like two years
my uh vocabulary and dictionary and
everything else because it's just not
true what other goals figure out how
they did this
and get on oh papa it makes it sound
like he was like in
you know um clockwork orange when he's
got his eye yeah some kind of
intense racial reprogramming
we gotta get the m word out my
vocabulary
that turns me on well at least it's
progress right i mean at least he's
trying
to get the n word out of his vocabulary
you know i love pizza and i love people
saw people saying it's like he's in a
12-step program for the n-word
my name's papa and i used the n-word
what did he just misspeak or is that
really what he meant
i think so because yeah i think he
misspoke because if you listen to what
he says immediately after that
he says because it's just not true yeah
which doesn't really make sense in the
comments
out of my vocabulary i i think he meant
like papa what are you saying i don't
really know what it is
i've been training for this moment
you've been preparing i've had you on
i've tried to get you to say [ __ ] like
this and you never do
you know
i mean and and you're so good and you're
so careful and then you go on aon and
say i'm trying to get the n-word out of
the vocabulary
i used to lay in bed just going how did
they do this and we've had three goals
for the last two months to get rid of
this uh
n word uh in my uh vocabulary
and dictionary he's even taken out of
the dictionary i'm thinking
man you think edward's in the dictionary
the ones he owns come on
man papa why are you doing this
you know you're getting so close to and
everything else
you got to stop doing press like just
just
what is this chiron to the depths of
cancel culture i mean
even by his own narrative it wasn't
really cancel culture it was more of
like a
frame job yeah like a corporate
espionage
yeah that's a good kind of i mean the
whole right like extreme right-wing
media it's like everything's just
cancel culture kind of you could sell
pretty much anything
because it's just not true the bro these
people are going on and on about dr
seuss it was dr seuss's own publishing
company it's not
cancel culture the company itself
decided not to publish the [ __ ] books
if you want to have an opinion about it
that's fine but it's it's
dr seuss's [ __ ] foundation decided
not to publish those books like
you know what i love too because nothing
was cancelled and you keep seeing people
that are standing up for dr seuss uh
appearing in things showing uh
it was his family it was his estate they
made the decision you dumb [ __ ]
right and and you know they're they're
holding like green eggs and ham and like
i'm not letting
that one wasn't cancelled exactly and i
i want to see
i want to see ted cruz sitting there
with with the picture
of you know the [ __ ] drawings or
whatever and be like
i'm not letting you know this exactly
that turns me on
i'm just saying like these people are so
[ __ ] dishonest like you can disagree
okay
but it was his family it was his estate
his publishing company that decided to
stop printing them they were not
cancelled by anyone
this was a conscious decision by them to
not print these books
that's like papa saying i don't want to
say the n word anymore and be like
cancel culture
it's like papa says he's working hard to
get the n word out of his vocabulary
he's been training for years at this
point
literally years
can you imagine it makes it sound like
before he was just popping off with the
n word all the time
yeah i mean again to give him a little
bit of the benefit of the doubt i think
he just misspoke because
the full sentence doesn't even really
make sense figure out how they did this
and get on with my life if papa john's
would just say
hey we got in a hurry we didn't follow
proper
take me back because i've talked to papa
i i don't that is certainly not
consistent with the things he's he's
told me
this isn't my first rodeo still funny
though it's hilarious like you can't say
that papa
[Applause]
i had two goals the people the pizza
and not saying the n-word
now there's all these again now there's
all these memes of papa
mother here here's here's the n-word
training papa's undergoing
he's working hard papa john when you
asked him who was in paris i don't get
that
it's a reference to the kanye song oh
got it papa flex papa john purging the
edward ava's vocabulary for 20 plus
months
oh papa month 21 for papa john
uh oh watch out for that creeping n word
papa john when gold digger starts
playing
yeah it's tough it can be hard
to resist we even have videos
of papa john trying not to just another
meme but the video was just so funny
papa john n word training when he wants
to let one rip desperately
[Music]
hey no stop just calm down
don't do it look stop
you know those dbz characters trained
harder than anyone
that's true you know
papa john try not to say the n word
vegeta what's going on something's
attacking me don't do it
hold it in we can't see anything
yeah he looks like he's doing good i
mean he's trying
you guys following the whole uh oprah
queen of england royal family [ __ ]
it's impossible not to i i don't want to
why does anyone care
about the royal [ __ ] family yeah i
don't know
especially in america like holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
you know
the whole thing is here let me pull this
up
uh prince harry what's his name prince
harry
yeah he married on the half black woman
and apparently the royal family was not
down with having a black person in their
family according to them
they were concerned about how dark the
baby's
skin might be they also said they would
not give their baby a title
or security they basically not accept
their son as a royal
sounds super racist and [ __ ] up to me
[Music]
and i'm not surprised that the royal
family is racist i mean
yeah i mean apparently they're all
inbred too i didn't know that like their
whole family tree is like a circle
yeah all of the nobles from europe
because they all i just the whole royal
family thing is odd like they don't do
anything
they have no power they are
they're just like nice like decorative
it's like a nice decorative piece for
the i don't know you're
you're half english in ian what do you
think about all this
what's your dad think about all this i'm
curious
uh he doesn't really engage with this
you know side of
of english culture you know i mean it's
all very
superfluous and kind of you know
so not all english people are invested
in this
no no no no
i mean even in england there's a sizable
amount of people that want to uh abolish
the monarchy
oh my goodness please for the love of
god we've been dude americans made the
best choice like what three four
three hundred whatever years ago to be
like [ __ ] this
yeah we don't need this [ __ ] that's not
your idea
we bow to no man in america
we bow to no man kiss the ring
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what and
who who is having that conversation
it was definitely the um was definitely
the what's his their dad his dad because
they went on record like it wasn't the
queen
or the queen's husband so i was like
okay it was their dad
charles right prince charles
what i can't keep straight so who's who
and
that whole thing anyway she said that
yeah they didn't want a black baby
and um
which is [ __ ] up obviously it's like
insanely [ __ ] up
and then the other revelation was that
she's suicidal because by the way the
media coverage i've seen is just
it's like [ __ ] horrid
it's like horror people are so mean to
her
the the tabloid culture in england is it
makes
ours seem incredibly tame like like we
were talking recently about the
paparazzi with britney or whatever
that's like
nothing compared to what cruel to her
like oh my god it's on and then you see
someone like pierce morgan who like had
a whole thing because he was like
i [ __ ] hate her she's lying let's
pull up that pierce morgan clip
i i just heard that he uh last night
that he quit
yeah he laughs he's also being
investigated now apparently i don't know
what that means apparently in
england you can't say whatever you want
in the media uh
the libel laws in england are far
far stricter than they are in america
you know how we've we've been talking
recently about defamation because of all
the ship with uh david and everything
and how
it's extremely difficult to sue somebody
for uh slander defamation in the united
states that that is not the case in
england
well it's a little bit she said it's a
little bit um
it's a little bit [ __ ] up for a news
man to come out and be like she's
lying i mean she's sharing her story
what what evidence do you have if she's
lying about anything
so i think it's just a different
philosophy where
someone like here like a rachel maddow
or bill o'reilly or whoever
sean hannity could come out and be like
you know obama wasn't born in america
or whatever the [ __ ] they say that's
crazy versus in england
you have to have some yeah there's a
little bit more of an obligation to
say true things she's probably good
honestly she said anything about you
since she cut you off
i don't think
we'll do it live [ __ ] it
i hate when people come on to explain
because it makes me feel like what i'm
doing is dumb
because i hate that [ __ ] so much when
that girl comes on it's like
that was pierce morgan storming out of
the set it's like no that's what i'm
doing
don't make me think about it
it makes you a little self-conscious i
guess
um anyway i don't know
i'm glad they ain't my problem bro the
royal family shit's so dumb the whole
notion of inheriting power
power prestige like that people honor
that i mean
the whole american notion is that we
the idea of royalty like meritocracy
through
bloodline is just a horrible way to
decide
yeah i mean we're not succession really
free from that
totally here but it's a little well if
somebody was formalized
if somebody goes out and makes a bunch
of [ __ ] money like bezos and his
family's gonna be rich forever
they still did that through his bezos
own merit i'm not saying i
think that that's better than just like
oh
my mom is queen and so now i'm king
yeah no doubt that uh that yeah i mean
obviously monarchy is insane
and archaic and it's crazy that it still
exists in britain
but um yeah i mean there's something to
be said about the queen's
inherited yeah inherited wealth in the
united states still
offers a lot of power but it's not as
formalized
you don't have an actual [ __ ] title
some people might [ __ ] [ __ ] the queen
though who [ __ ] cares
i call anyone else i'll call wendy
williams an old hag and you don't see
her people like trying to kill me about
it
how is she still alive wendy williams i
know it's crazy
no i don't know there's something dude
they have some kind of like secret
technology in that buckingham palace
because
bro the queen and her husband are still
alive and those people are so gripping
on the left like
what's her husband's name prince
isn't charles no charles is the son son
the son um
prince philip philip is the uh that
[ __ ] yeah he's like a
cadaver that picture of him in the car
hold on here look at that y'all this is
him
driving look at this
that guy that's not a real living person
there's definitely some spirit cooking
going on in buckingham palace
well uh he is 99 years old to be fair so
but
we'll see how we look at 99. hey
of course but i'm just saying like the
the average lifespan of people coming
out that palace is insane
uh yeah and the queen is 94. so yeah
they're she's still writing speeches and
press releases
she's still so stylish bro
and she looks pretty good actually she
looks really good that's photoshopped as
[ __ ] let me see the real [ __ ]
and she's she's looking pretty old these
days but um
yeah they don't they're not letting
those candied photos out so much
like that one of pr of uh phillip
yeah why is this so little because
there's been so much talk about
uh the royal family um she looks pretty
good i'm not even gonna hate on
on the queen 94 years old what can you
say
right damn her son is like old as [ __ ]
like he's supposed to
he's supposed to be the next king right
yeah this guy prince charles yeah
yeah i mean i think he might not even
make it at this rate yeah i think he's
in
his 70s his 70s and his mind's like
mom come on where's my chance uh she's
uh i believe has the record for the
longest reigning
monarch in history baller ass [ __ ]
i think or just she's i think charles is
pissed because he's like mom come on
just croak already i want to be king
with this [ __ ] i don't have much time
left
he's gonna be king for like two years if
at all she should have stepped down
years ago
there's always been like wait can you
step down oh apparently louis xiv
uh reigned for 72 years but i think um
the queen's up there wait can she step
down i'm not sure is that
she can abdicate yes she can yeah oh so
why is
so why is she she is such
she rules with the iron fist she doesn't
want to give it up for her son
right she don't want to give up the
power
she loves it
spirit cooking how black is our grand
boy gonna be
what is the hue of his color do you
think
the white is it going to be not quite
but
is it going to be an off white or more
of a
malato more of a coffee color
oh as long as it's not darker than
coffee
if it's darker than coffee i simply
don't know what we're going to do
megan is only half black and
charles is very white if you
if we can get a light chocolate color i
think that would be fine but anything
less will simply not do
hmm
[Music]
this is a little this is a [ __ ]
conversation that took place for real
no doubt a black baby will simply not do
we have we must strip him of all his
titles
we cannot have a black winter unless of
course his
if his color skin color is between
off-white a light cream off-white
and possibly on the upper edge of
acorn brown oh my
oh my
if the baby's skin color is darker
than chestnut it will simply not do
they've got like a whole color wheel out
um they're holding up to a picture of
megan
[Music]
we have grave concerns about the color
of your baby your majesty
[Music]
bring out the color wheel break out the
color wheel
oh somewhere between
toffee and
whoa
bro you know that's what the
conversation was like
ian cut the end you uncomfortable with
this
go as long as you want we should bring
in the
after this let's do the um
the italian voice too let's do it back
tomorrow god why would you say that why
are you doing that
oh bring me the color wheel
megan is pregnant
do you think the queen gets a baby blood
injected into her
keeper alive oh for sure they're spirit
cooking look how good how old she is bro
was the queen kind of hot back in the
day would she smash
yeah back in the day back in the busy
because in the crown she always looks
pretty good like the actresses but
that's like hollywood so i wasn't sure
and she looks very beautiful quite a
catch
look at her dude the royal grenade
what the [ __ ] is this it just looks like
a bomb what is it
a grenade is there like holy water the
holy hand grenade
yeah exactly is it just holy water that
she can lob at the infidels or what
i don't know
if you told me back then that i would
have a black
grandchild i will call you crazy
[Music]
but here i am how my life has come
great grandchild right great grandchild
she looked good back in the day
[Music]
it's like easily like a [ __ ]
you know definitely smash
won't smash your pass
it's quite a catch man
yeah anyway you know the other [ __ ] they
say about megan is like oh she was a
[ __ ]
literal princess and she lived in a
palace how could she be
how could she complain about being
suicidal it's like you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] how
shut the [ __ ] up i mean if you watch any
season you do that you know being inside
that palace is miserable
yeah it's one of the most uh evil places
on the planet
you saying that as a gag the british
crown
definitely has you think there's means
some some bad juju
for sure we're talking about
one of the most murderous regimes in
history right i mean colonialism yeah
they do better than anyone for sure
[ __ ] henry viii created his own
religion so he could get a divorce
my man hey i think people would say that
i think that her life is just going to
be like a princess diaries
like diaries princess diaries yeah
that disney movie yeah ruby defensive
diaries
i mean they think that she's just moving
is this coming from the tulip guy
why are you citing a [ __ ] disney
movie right now because he's saying that
that she probably imagined it would be
like a fairy tale thing but the reality
of it was uh
people who are saying that she should
have been happy i'm saying yeah that's
what they think
that it was just well to be yeah if i
can criticize her a little bit in the
oprah interview she goes
i had no idea what it would be like it's
like really
you're marrying the son of princess
diana you don't know what it's going to
be like i don't know
i love looking at pictures of him he's
so old bro
he was pretty handsome back in the day
too i'd smash him
dude yeah dude he was handsome as [ __ ]
let's go
prince philip and somehow they're
cousins they're like first cousins
that's how it goes usually with these
that's awesome
and i [ __ ] my cousin and everyone gets
mad
somehow they get married and nobody
cares well because
they're of high birth they have noble
blood you know
it's different no my blood is anything
but noble
i have dirty jew blood as david dobrik
would say
all right how many times have been
canceled today
maybe just the one i don't know about
the color wheel
yeah yeah well just just all the
[ __ ] on on
the bro oh you think people are mad that
i [ __ ] on the crown well that's one
thing there's a lot of people who
really uh feel very defensive what do
you want
i imagine that would be considered
somewhat disrespectful as well but
again [ __ ] the queen i never said [ __ ]
the queen
all right um anything else let's see
what we got here
banksy you want to talk about burger
king put out a tweet that lit a fire
under everybody's ass
they said on international women's day
women belong in the kitchen
straight up they tweeted that
and then they followed it up burger king
uk once again
the english wild and out but then they
followed it up with the
made you look they said if they want to
of course yet only 20
of chefs are women we're on a mission to
change the gender ratio
and restaurant industry what are you
saying burger king you want more burger
king female burger king
chefs what can you do for them burger
king
you know i would say boycott burger king
but i am [ __ ] eating there in like 15
years
i've been boycotting them for 15 years
unintentionally
they were always the worst i mean i
haven't had it in yours either i don't
know if it's changed but um
yeah they're bad i'm surprised they're
in business man when i was a kid there
was a mcdonald's and a burger king next
to each other
like some kind of game theory [ __ ] i
don't know but like
who would go to burger king when it's
next to mcdonald's like that is just a
losing location
you know oh yeah and sure enough i mean
mcdonald's was popping off and nobody
was in that bird can
drive out drive through well burger king
never had the playpen for the kids so
who who the [ __ ] wants to go if you
can't jump in a ball pit and [ __ ]
yeah that ball pit i've thought about
that since i've got that [ __ ] has got to
be so unsanitary totally
like i never thought about that as a kid
well you're jumping a ball pit
dirty ass hands coughing spit you're
breathing heavy you got snot coming out
your nose piss and [ __ ] themselves
constantly
and you know how do you wash balls how
do you sanitize a ball pit
you don't i don't think you do one of my
one of my earliest memories is going to
uh don't you say you [ __ ] in a ball pit
zack
no no no no [ __ ] a lot of places but not
a ball pit yeah i
saw a kid [ __ ] and it traumatized me
in the ball pit in the [ __ ] ball oh
man that's just gonna get on every ball
and so
so where was it that that happened it
was at a mcdonald's playground oh yeah
did anything happen while you were there
i mean my my mom's thought she pulled me
out quick and you know they put
you know the hazards was he squatting
what happened how did he [ __ ] in the
ball
he pulled his pants down
you know what's great is they'll
probably send someone in there to clean
it
and then just forget it ever happens the
ball is like it's basically a liquid
body so the [ __ ] is
circulating everywhere you got [ __ ]
molecules on all those balls and i
guarantee you they never sanitize that
because how can you there's there's
doo-doo feces everywhere
oh jesus theodore's gonna want to play
in a ball pit one of these days and be
like son
we gotta talk about the ball pit
just don't let him see don't just keep
him ignorant
he doesn't know such a thing exists yet
yeah i don't know
i mean who goes inside of mcdonald's
anyway i mean that's kind of trashy
in this day and age excuse me to go
inside of a mcdonald's who would do such
a thing
to go dying inside of a mcdonald's dude
it's an experience
the [ __ ] are you talking about like it's
just why not just go through the
drive-in why do you have to go inside
the mcdonald's
you don't have a car there maybe you
don't have a car
well we're older now but when you're a
kid that's like you get a [ __ ] happy
meal
exactly it's like an experience and you
go you climb around in the tubes and
[ __ ]
there's a great time yeah these
mcdonald's yeah
yeah exactly it's a mini disneyland in
there
now you're canceled you were saying how
many times i get canceled this is it
before before a person discovers
masturbation i mean that's the best fun
they have you know
zach i feel like
so you're saying before you masturbated
your favorite thing was
mcdonald's i was making an analogy here
but yeah you know hopefully there's no
overlap
it's just you know someone jerked off in
that ball pit though
like oh of course well somebody at some
point probably who jerk off in a sealed
baggie
and then they go to mcdonald like these
creeps you know like james charles
they he probably jizz in his bag seal it
up
go into the ball pit dump it in just
because he gets off on knowing that it's
in there
and then all this i'm just telling you
that happens do you think this probably
happens
you think it's like i'm not ruling
anything out of a mcdonald's ball pit
everything happens in a mcdonald's ball
pit
maybe not the ball pit but definitely
the bathroom because there's some
[ __ ]
horror stories any bathroom i go in i
just assume there's jizz everywhere yeah
that's that's a safe assumption actually
i don't know man i try to avoid going to
mcdonald's at all costs but i understand
if you don't have a car
you know what choice do you have they
got them kind of nice in there they
they've redone them it's got kind of
like a cafe vibe and a lot of them
nowadays
yeah their breakfast is next to none
it's the it's the most amazing thing
for breakfast yeah dude it's not that
good
what the [ __ ] you talking about it's so
good you just mean for like fast food
like comparison yeah
yeah yeah okay i'll give you that yeah
for fast food breakfasts
all right hash browns yeah dude
anything else guys about mcdonald's
breakfast we want to add before we wrap
it up
were any of you guys into the [ __ ]
mcdonald's the
the pancakes that they sell there oh
yeah those [ __ ] lunatics that eat
those pancakes from mcdonald's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
why what's up a week ago
disgusting pancakes they're like the
worst pancakes
in the history of mankind i mean i'd
rather you think about the bus
i'd rather eat a [ __ ] flapjack from
like an old prospector in the west
than uh ian's about this is far-fetched
dude oh ian
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's
going on hey what do you got hold that
up
hold it up somebody just make that for
you
is that a lobster roll it's a lobster
blt
what the [ __ ] i'm hungry ian's eating
good over
you guys keep talking about your
mcdonald's pancake cake or whatever
you agree that their dog should right
ian back me up here
yeah well they got rid of them right
because they're so bad oh really get rid
of them i had them a week ago
dude they're good i don't know what i
don't know i agree with abe
how bad can it be it's just a [ __ ]
pancake it's it's the taste of childhood
for me i think it's more than just good
i think they're like really good
what the [ __ ] i don't know
all right guys i'm sure
that people would love to hear our take
on all the fast food
yeah it was but let's save it for
another day
that's been like a quarter of the
content that we've made on the show over
the years that's true
we need a more well why don't we do like
fast food breakfast foods that'd be fun
taste test
[Music]
that's one i can actually participate in
let's do that we haven't done a food
taste test in a while
yeah i've never had the chick-fil-a
breakfast
ew what could we do no it's everywhere
every day it's
so good i don't eat a chick-fil-a
there's a bunch of [ __ ]
homophobes over there so here
how many chicken sandwiches before they
stone a gay person
on your behalf wake up i think that's
one more tear up i haven't reached that
one yeah we will we will stone a gay
person
in your name wait are you not meaning
there's like a there's like a
a tier like a customer tier uh
system yeah yeah there is
you have like a membership card you
chick-fil-a member
no you you pop open the app oh careful
don't show it don't show your number
every time you go yeah i'm careful
then you go to your account and i'm
chick-fil-a one red member
how many sandwiches you have you earned
so far
oh so many really you go there a lot one
more tier above me
ian says he goes to chick-fil-a like
daily you eat a chick-fil-a every day
what's your order i've stopped because
i'm on the jet hanks health challenge
right right what's your what's your
order
uh they're market stuff with the apple
cider vinaigrette
that's the go-to you say you get a salad
from chick-fil-a
yeah wow that's weird or they're egg
white grill breakfast sandwich is pretty
good
so you don't even get [ __ ] chicken
sandwiches odd
i mean their spicy deluxe is good but
it's heavy
it's really good it's great heavy
chicken sandwiches you know blow your
blood hold on a little bit so you don't
want it too often
it's a treat your internet's taken a
little bit of a crap i appreciate you
thank you
got that jungle internet thank you so
much
all right well ian started eating his
lobster roll
adam not sure how do we feel about
eating a sandwich during the show
i think it's incredibly rude to eat
during the show and
nobody should ever ever well there's a
different thing popping a chip in your
mouth but just having full-blown lunch
seems like a lot he's chomping like he
can't talk if i ask him a question he'd
be unable to respond
like ian emergency question about ntfs
what do uh what's the status did you get
the coins in your wallet
go ahead and answer right now that
ethereum i've been chugging the water
nice cover nice cover all right this is
over you guys
this is such a mess right now this is
off the rails is this this
these wednesday episodes are off the
[ __ ] rails bro i don't even know
i think people dig it
the super simp has spoken
all right well if nothing i'm really
excited to see what happens with these
coins
so that's gonna get you all the
breakfast sandwiches you ever dreamed
and wanted
um oh you were saying if we sell we
could go somewhere special will you take
us all to the ball pit at mcdonald's oh
yeah
let's all go let's all go have a jizz
fest in the ball pit
please papa ethan please yes zack
you know what we should do you know what
bro oh
yo this is for real ian you gotta go
down to a
mcdonald's ball pit take one of the
balls and then we got to give it to one
of these chemists to do an analysis
on all the bacteria and [ __ ] on the ball
that would be
so [ __ ] interesting
we just need someone to steal a ball put
it in a bag so you don't contaminate it
and i'll find there's like on tick tock
there's these guys
that put random [ __ ] under a telescope
to see what kind of bacteria
so i'll i'm going to contact one of
these guys and we can mail it to him
he can even do a video on it i love it
it's probably super
super coveted yes there's like here's a
covey
oh they're probably not even open right
now like the they probably have them
no i need that ball pit but what what's
up
well yeah the ball pit's probably closed
if you can get one of those balls
zach get one of those [ __ ] balls and
put it in a plastic bag
okay you got it make sure you wear
gloves when you do it i'm sure they
won't know you're just you've got the
poopy hands
you got the [ __ ] poopy hand you're
going to get that it'll be awesome if
you took a [ __ ] on the ball
i'll do it i'll film it it'd be great
not to tell us though it'd be great
content yeah be great
i think we might get sued by mcdonald's
it's like these balls are
covered in feces would you post my bail
if i get caught just taking a
batch no bro i'm not in on this
how are they going to call us a liar
they'll subpoena us
they'll subpoena us they'll have all of
our messages about zach sending a
picture of him [ __ ] on the ball
no but seriously get one of those balls
and
this is going to be such a great
experiment i'll do i'll do my recon work
i'm excited all right let's wrap it up
how long we've been going here dan
uh an hour 50. so yeah let's wrap it up
i think we said it and done it all can't
go over that two hour limit
well guys thank you for coming in and
watching off the rails
with off the rails without ela cline
with ethan klein experience
aka the board aka the boys but all girls
welcome because
you know we like the girls and we
appreciate them watching
yeah girls can be one of the boys you
know
yeah it's a state of mind the boys yeah
more than anything
okay well we will be back on friday
with ela live everybody loves after dark
we will see you then
until then tata god bless stay well buy
our coins
um please buy our tokens tokens
don't buy mine